that's what I'm talking about the hobbit
the desolation of smaug and Tolkien EES
au is owl like Sauron or smell bored
Smaug don't worry no spoilers in this
review there's spoiler review that comes
later
so the hobbit the desolation of Smaug is
part two of The Hobbit trilogy and the
first one the Hobbit an unexpected
journey was a fun time I had a couple of
pacing issues with it but all in all I
own it on blu-ray I watch it and it's
good the desolation of Smaug oh holy
I feel like this is more the tone
that people wanted when they were going
into the first Hobbit movie this is
next-level how a sequel should be
you already had your character
introductions done in the last movie so
this movie starts out exciting and
relatively speaking holds it for the
most part till the end of the movie till
you cut two credits because this is it
this is the thick of it they're like
alright we're going to the mountain
we're gonna take on the dragon Smaug I
mean everyone still does a great job in
the roles that they play in this movie
Martin Freeman is the best Bilbo they
could have gotten every and McKellen
still kills it as Gandalf the Grey I
personally like Gandalf the Grey over
Gandalf the white because he's just he's
more fun new to be Thorin Oakenshield is
still the he's much more Aragorn
ish in this movie the like become the
king you're supposed to be I'm like I
recognize that he's like I'm Aragorn and
Boromir had a kid how could I not have
like a man crush on that dude or dwarf
crush it would be a dwarf crush can I
say this movie's exciting I really mean
it is really exciting you know that
scene in the trailer you saw where
they're all in the barrels and they're
going down the river I saw that in the
trailer and I was like alright that'll
probably be fine but in the end I feel
like it was some theme park ride pitch
for kids no not at all that's one of the
scenes I remember most vividly about
this movie that was awesome it was
exciting a lot of stuffs happening
arrows are going through heads in really
cool stylistic kind of ways most of
those props go to Evangeline Lilly and
Orlando Bloom I also thought I was gonna
walk out of this movie gun alright those
two were completely shoehorned into this
movie for the sake of them being in the
movie and there probably were but I say
if you're gonna shoot one something into
a movie make it memorable make it badass
guess what they were memorable and
badass I'm telling you got to see it to
know what I'm talking about this dude is
business and
actually liked Evangeline Lilly's
character also there's a bit of interest
going on with her and one of the dwarves
I get it they're from two worlds and
that's intriguing it's morbid curiosity
kind of thing although she clearly wants
to sit on his little dwarf face but it's
not done in a cheesy way that's what I
like about it the only flaw is I found
in the movie r1 a couple of times the
CGI looked a little CGI edge this is
white out these are the cgi gods but a
couple of times I was like that could
have been cleaned up and the soundtrack
I liked the music in the movie as I'm
watching the movie but I didn't walk out
of the movie going I need to buy that
soundtrack and listen to it when I'm not
watching the movie an unexpected journey
I have that soundtrack I listen to that
soundtrack actively because there are a
lot of tracks in there that I really
like and I felt like that the moment I
stepped out of the movie for the first
time this movie I stepped out I was like
you the music was good while I was
watching it but I don't have to put in
the earbuds and just rock that
right now and this one segment in the
movie that does slow down I thought
about it I was like maybe it slows down
relatively speaking because a lot of
exciting happens in this movie so
when you get to Fishtown it feels like
it's boring but I can't all be action
you got to slow down at some point I'm
not gonna say that's negative it's just
something I need to address well folks
I'm gonna get right into it
Smaug the dragon how is he he's alright
surely dude was badass he's not
even a dude he's a dragon but he was so
cool I'm gonna remember this dragon for
the rest of my life
that's right Wicked Witch of the West
Balrog of Morgoth Darth Vader Voldemort
Smaug the dragon I just like how he was
made in the movie he's enormous he's
articulate he's evil he's menacing he's
dominating voiced by Benedict
Cumberbatch and I will tell you right
now that is one big batch of cumbersome
how did not disappoint me at all and I'm
gonna put some minds at ease here those
of you who thought oh they showed him in
the trailer and they shouldn't have done
that only part of the experience is
completely ruined it's not you haven't
seen anything yet you haven't seen Smaug
I was scared like when Bilbo first sees
him you know what he feels like cuz
we've all played an MMO or something
where you round a corner and there's a
big boss there and you pull him and
you're like oh that dude's red I can't
take him on Elisha get the it is
like that you see it in Bilbo's face and
yours you're making the same face Bilbo
is making and these are not bad things
in the end the hobbit the desolation of
smaug was great it was exciting it was
fun it had good themes to it
does touch on the fact that there are
other things out there you don't need to
have a ring we all have a ring thing
that can consume us movie touches on
that that's an important theme of life
does it have a lot of things in this
movie that are not in the book oh yeah
for sure but I reached all the steps of
acceptance on that fact a long time ago
like I said if a movie's gonna take a
license make it cool and memorable this
movie did I'm so glad I get to say this
I'm gonna warm up my friends the hobbit
the desolation of smaug is awesome
tacular and i fanboying out right now
absolutely doesn't mean it's not
justified I'm saying it is justified so
the hobbit the desolation of smaug have
you seen it are you gonna see it what
did you think about it I guess that last
part wouldn't pertain to you if you
haven't seen it yet however whatever
your thoughts are comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more